اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحم
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الس
[Silence]
‏use gum and all the
are and trans that into
are
uction are
‏pleas
make
prop take care
[Silence]
السلام
عل تبرات انشاالله نماز شروع مخنن نماز
نماز اول بعد از ر ساعت بعد نماز دوم خطبه
شروع مشه ساعت ه بجه بعد از او ماا صبح
دارم در جم نزم شاا صبح برا هم آماده ه
نوش جان خنن و دوم دهه ذر بردن آقا مقصود
صاحب بفتن موتتان ا به جاهار باشه متوان
همو را از شما زود تر از اجا برا موتر خود
از جا بشم ر مردم اذت نشوه
د انشاالله دقه بعد نماز اول شروع مشش
بخر
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وب سبان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وازم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا ايا
مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محم مم وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
وله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
يا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
ايا مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج سيدنا
مد و ذ
سدنا
محمد محمل
[Silence]
‏morning
‏any un
sit so
pleas
serv morning
so be do any un
sit how
وعلى
وح شاء
اللهه ا ابو حنفه رحمه الله تعالى عليه ان
شاء
اللهب
الاحرام سه
الفاتحه ان شاء الله
تعالى بالعربي ان شاء الله صلاتها ستكون
على مذهب الامام ابي حنيفه النمان بن ثابت
الكوفي رضي الله عنه اربع تكبيرات في
الركعه الاولى مع تكبيره الاحرام نتد
بالتكبيرات وترفع يدك في التكبيرات ترفع
يدك في التكبيرات
ثم بعد ذلك نبدا ابدا بقراءه سوره الفاتحه
وسوره معها ثم اذهب الى الركوع في الركعه
الثانيه في الركعه الثانيه سابدا بقراءه
سوره الفاتحه وسوره معها ثم ابدا
بالتكبيرات
ثلاث تكبيرات ثم التكبيره الرابعه اذهب
الى الركوع ومن السنه رفع اليد في
التكبيرات الزوائد في العيد
جزاكم الله خير وبارك الله
[Silence]
فيكم
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين هل اتاك حديث
الغاشيه
وجوه يومئذ
خاشعه عامله
ناصبه تصلى نارا
حاميه تسقى من عين
انيه ليس لهم طعام الا من
ضريع لا يسمن ولا يغني من جو
وجوه
يومئذ
ناعمه لسعيها
راضيه في جنه
عاليه لا تسمع فيها
لاغيه فيها عين
جاريه فيها سرر
مرفوعه
ونمارق
مصفوفه
واكواب
موضوعه
ونمارق
مصفوفه
وزرابي
مبثوثه افلا
وينظرون الى الابل كيف
خلقت والى
السماء كيف
رفعت والى الجبال كيف
نصبت والى الارض كيف
سطحت فذكر انما
انت
مذكر لست عليهم بمسيطر
الا من تولى
وكفر
فيعذبه الله العذاب
الاكبر ان
الينا
ايابهم ثم ان علينا حساب
هم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين والفجر
وليال
عشر والشفع
والوتر والليل اذا
يسر هل في ذلك قسم لذي
حجر الم تر كيف فعل ربك
بعاد
رمت العباد
التي لم يخلق مثلها في
البلاد وثمود الذين جابوا الصفر
بالواد
وفرعون ذي
الاوتاد الذين طغوا في البلاد
فاكثروا في
الفساد فصب عليهم ربك سوط
عذاب
ان ربك لبالمرصاد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله الحمد الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله
الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده نصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون الحمد لله رب
العالمين الحمد لله الذي بنعمته تتم
الصالحات
وعفوه تغفر
الذنوب
والسيئات
وبكر تقبل العطايا
والقربات
وبلطه تستر العيوب
والزلات الحمد لله الذي امات
واحيا ومنع
واعطى وارشد وهدى واضحك
وابكى الحمد لله الذي هدانا
لهذا وما كنا لنهتدي لولا ان هدانا الله
نحمده حمدا يليق بجلال وجهه وكمال صفاته
وعظيم
سلطانه يا ربنا لا نحصي ثنا
عليك انت كما اثنيت على نفسك واشهد ان لا
اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له له الملك
وله الحمد يحيي ويميت وهو على كل شيء قدير
واشهد ان سيدنا وحبيبنا
وشفيعنا ونبينا محمدا عبده ورسوله
وصفيه وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه
ونصح الامه وكشف الغمه تركنا على المحجه
البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا هالك صلى الله
عليه وعلى اله الطيبين واصحابه اجمعين ومن
وعلى نهجهم الى يوم الدين رضوان الله
تبارك وتعالى علينا وعليهم
اجمعين الله اكبر الله اكبر ما لبس الحجيج
ملابس
الاحرام الله اكبر ما راوا الكعبه فبدو
بالتحيه
والسلام الله اكبر ما استلموا الحجر
وطافوا بالبيت وصلوا وصلوا عند المقام
الله اكبر ما اهتدوا بنور القران وفرحوا
بهدي الاسلام الله اكبر ما وقف الحجيج في
صعيد عرفات الله اكبر ما تضرعوا في الصفا
والمروه بخالص الدعوات الله اكبر ما غفر
لهم رب
وتحمل عنهم التبعات الله اكبر ما رموا
وحلقوا وتحلوا ونحر فتمت بذلك حجه الاسلام
الله اكبر كبيرا والحمد لله كثيرا وسبحان
الله بكره
واصيلا ايها
المسلمون ما
‏are
day
this
and this
day سيدنا ابراهيم الخليل عليه
السلام الله سبحانه وتعالى تدرس عند قران
عند سوره
الصافات وقال اني ذاهب الى ربي
سدي رب هبلي من
الصالحين فبشرنا
بغلام
حليم
فلما بلغ معه السعي قال يا
بني قال يا بني
اني ارى في المنام
اني اذبحك فانظر ماذا
ترى قال يا ابتي اعل ما تؤمر ستجدني
ان
شاء الله من
الصابرين
فلما اسلما وت له
للجبين
وناديناه ان يا
ابراهيم قد صدقت
الرؤيا انا كذلك نجزي المحسنين
ان هذا لهو
البلا
المبين
وفديناه بذبح
عظيم وتركنا عليه في
الاخرين سلام
على
ابراهيم بف
ايات في سوره
الصافات
ايات سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام وبي الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
و مدينه الخليل و
فلسطين اسماعيل عليه
السلام
المسجد الكعبه المشرفه
وين سيدنا
ابراهيم عليه
السلام وين سيدنا اسماعيل عليه السلام
[Silence]
يا ابت اعل ما
تؤمر
الله فلما اسلم وت للجبين
[Silence]
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم ح عليه الصلاه
والسلام صلى الله عليه
وسلم
خطبه ى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏good s
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام جبريل عليه السلامن
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله الله اكبر الله
اكبر ابراهيم جبريل عليه السلام
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
لاه سيدنا اسمايل عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
و الله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد اللهم يا
الله اجعل يومنا هذا يوما
عظيما اللهم لنا اخوه في فلسطين
يعانون
ويقتلون
ويهجرون ونحن هنا نحتفل فيا امه
الاسلام متى نستيقظ من هذه الغفله متى وون
وحده كامله فقد تكالبت علينا
الامم كما تتكالب الاكله على
قصعتها نعم ايها الاخوه اصابنا الوهن
اصابنا الوهن والوهن حب الدنيا وكراهيه
الموت نحتاج الى عمر جديد نحتاج الى خالد
بن الوليد نحتاج
الى ابي عبيده ابن الجراح نحتاج الى صلاح
الدين جديد لتحر القدس ونصلي جمعا في
المسجد الاقصى اللهم انصر اخواننا في
فلسطين اللهم ارحم
شهدائهم اللهم اشفي جرحاهم اللهم عاوي
نازح اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين واعل
في كلمتي الحق والدين اقول قولي هذا
واستغفر الله العظيم لي ولكم ولوالدي
ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين ويا فوز
المستغفرين استغفروا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحم ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا انك انت
التواب رحيم اللهم اغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما
اخرنا وما اسررنا وما علمنا وما انت اعلم
به منا اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين وعلي
كلمتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم كن عونا
لاخواننا المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم انصر
امه محمد اللهم خذ بايدي امه محمد اللهم
رد امه محمد ردا جميلا ردنا الى الكتاب
والسنه ومنهج ومنهج السلف الصالح رضوان
الله تعالى عليهم اجمعين اللهم اغفر
لموتانا وموتى الجماعه الحاضرين ووالدينا
ووالديهم الذين شهدوا لك بالوحدانيه
ولنبيك بالرساله
وماتوا على ذلك اللهم من اراد بالمسلمين
سوء فاجعل دائره السوء تدور
عليه اللهم الاحزاب منزل الكتاب اهزمهم يا
رب العالمين زلزل الارض من تحت
اقدامهم يا
الله سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد كل عام وان ب
السلام
عليكم على
[Silence]
حياكم الله الجمان ما شاء الله نورت
والله شا
م مبارك يلا
[Silence]
خلي اشوفك يا
مع مبارك
[Silence]
لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله
الله
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
وله
الحمد الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده وصر
عبده واعز جنده وازب
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا عبد الا
اياه مخلصين له الدين ولو كه
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى
ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى عنصر
سيدنا محمد وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر ل الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وازم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى عنصر
سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليما كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده وده صدق وده
ونصر عبده
عز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو ك
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد و ذ
سيدنا
محمد وعلى يه
محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليما
كثيرا الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكب
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكب اكب لا ال
الله الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكب
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله
صيرا لا اله الا
الله صد وعده ونصر عبده وعز جده
وز وحده لا اله الا الله ولا ند الا ايا
مخلصين له الدين ولو ك
الكافرون اللهم صل على سي س
ممد
سدنا
ممد اصحب
سدنا محم
و
سدنا
محم ذ
محم انص
سدنا
محمد سلم تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
[Silence]
انش
الله
make care
[Silence]
‏make
‏you can do to
m make that done properly so we can take
care think
‏so pleas
make شا
الله
الله اكب
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكب الله اكبر وله
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله
اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
وله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره وصيله
لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
وله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره الله
اصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وجب
الاحزاب
وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى
انصار سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا محمد وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله
ا الحم
الله اكب
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكب الله اكب
وله الحم
[Silence]
‏pleas for
make that just make
that
all that and want make all
[Silence]
الله لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحم الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد ل
كثيرا
وسبحان الله مكره
واص لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
مخلصين له الدين ولو ك
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا محمد وعلى انصار
سدنا محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا السلام عل ان شاء
[Silence]
الله ان شاء الله pleas
‏please make sure
[Silence]
الله
سبحان الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله ا
الله اكبر الله اكب
الله اكبر الله اكبر سبحانك الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليه غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضال
امين هل اتاك حديث
الغاشيه
وجوه ذ خاشعه عامله
صه تصلى نارا
حاميه تسقى من عين
انيه ليس له طعام الا
من لا يسمن ولا يغني من
جوع وجوه
يومئذ لسع
راضيه في
جنه
عيه لا تسمع فيها
لايه فيها عين
جاريه فيها س
مرفوعه
وابواب
مضو
ومنار
مصفوفه
وزرا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
بسم الله الرح الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
افلا
ينظرون الى الابن كيف خلقت والى
السماء كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف نسبت
والى الارض كيف سطحت فذكر
انما انت
مذكر لست عليهم بمسيطر
الا من تولى
وكفر
فيعذبه الله العذاب
الاكبر
ان
الينا
ايابهم
ثم ان علينا
حسابهم الله اكبر
سم الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر السلام عليك
اد اللهم صل
الدنيا حسن
[Silence]
السلام علكم رحمه
الله السلام عليكم رحمه
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا
من يهد الله فلا مضل له ومن يدلله فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صفي
بل وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وعد الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف الله تعالى به وجاهد في الله
حق جهاد حت ا
اليقين اما بعد
سرح ايها اذين امن اه ولا تت
ومون ث
بعدق تالى و محد عليه
ورث مثه
وه الن
الل لا ماعلت وان تجعلن اذا شئ و ح ولاه
الا بالله العظي الله ربنا وقتنا ورجاؤنا
ومانا فنعم ونعم
[Silence]
مصل
علال back
we all knowing and all does
‏ands no ide
how when
you i
talk the
man today
الله
[Silence]
سالى
was was there ابم عليه الصلاه
والسلام فيع القوا الله
المحرم
legacy do
the and
[Silence]
عل
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الله ‏now today you always thise anding
because lst to practice makes
perfect pr gives consistency doesn't
make
perach if i learn to
choose you know learn the wrong i'm
never going make it i can practice all
day cons
الله as وو
سلمين
jis عليه واللام
عليه no sacrifice no
re عليهه
واللام دعام
[Silence]
‏the house
الله
things because heed us to be
lazy he bled us those things because he
give us eas so we can prac religion in
the
of how close to the legacy of
[Silence]
‏av
‏wife
from be cons
‏that a legacy
with so as wether today on this
blessed يه
[Silence]
‏was
only
most at you can't
all is in trou there
here how can can do this what can do for
[Silence]
‏havee to he not
man a
ى
[Silence]
سال
life do
have do
‏there
[Silence]
‏here
things
andes we
things in
way pushing
times best
[Silence]
الل الله اكب الله اك الله ا لا اله الله
ا اد اقول ت ولغم
[Silence]
الحمد لله الحمد للهدد الفر ل يلد و يد و
يك ل
[Silence]
اللهه
من
[Silence]
‏you
know cri
motheres as
العلا
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتى اول الع
الصلاه
[Silence]
اللهذا ‏to establish the of allah and
the
form not take us from this earth until
he happ and
us that estes us in this earth
as that orally
asked con and est
earth ss who the day
‏ask
allister year
and
all and those brothers and sisters not
opp toit the house either in
form coming this
year the and bur andy and the killing
and sisters first and for intin and
brother sisters in sud
‏sister sister ir sister
libia sisters in and
sister
sister sister
ch in
the wh are and
them from do not ex
[Silence]
في من هديت وعافينا في منفيت وتولنا في من
تيت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وكنا وصرفنا شر
ما قضيت انك تقض ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل
من ويت ولا يعذ من ديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اسالك من خير عاجله واجله
وما علمنا منه ولا لم ن نعلم ونعوذ بك من
شر كله عاجله واجله وما علمنا منه وما لم
نعلم اللهم نسالك من خير ما سالك عبدك ونب
ونعوذ بك من شر ما عا عبدك ونبي اللهم
نالك الجنه اللهم نسالك الجنه اللهم نسالك
الجنه وما قرب اليه من قول عمل ونعوذ بك
من النار ونعوذ بك من النار ونعوذ بك من
النار وما قرب اليه من ق العمل ونسالك ان
تجعل كل قضاء قضيه لنا خير وعيدكم مبارك
تقبل الله منكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[Silence]
عليي بارك الله فيك
الله امين امين
امين
م سبحانه وتعال
[Silence]
امين ام
الحمد ان شا الله
[Silence]
‏home ‏waiting for somebody to show up
to xbox
360 on there
[Silence]
‏up